black screen they say
[Music]
okay hello hello everybody
um I'm glad you are all here and I'll
try to make sense already I've seen the
discussion in the chat and you have it
right it's impossible to avoid all the
mistakes the lectures over no no wait
one minute
okay so yes indeed even the best of us
like Magnus Carson and these guys they
do make mistakes so well it just they
make
much less of them that we do
and the idea of this lecture it's
actually
uh ages quite a few years back when I
was invited to some Club in Norway to
have a lecture on a free subject and
then I thought okay the easy is the most
tempting ways of course to to brag about
me being able to chess player a big
couple of games that I won accidentally
and just to show off but then I realized
like everyone does it
and the idea for this one
uh has actually come from
yeah we do make mistakes it's
perhaps possible to categorize them in
some way
but and there are books on this right
there are books on this like people say
Okay terrible blunders or then someone
did not survive the opening or putting
opening catastrophes and so on but then
it's always the speculation right so
chicorian blundering Checkmate in two
against steinits in this game that he
should have won for instance
but we don't know what was going through
his head and my idea for this lecture
that I'll be dealing with examples uh of
chess player that I know the best that's
myself right so I would exactly know
what I was thinking in the moment when I
played The Batman
said at least this should be helpful
uh right and that's with all honesty
it's a subject that can go on and on and
on so I don't know how much I will fit
in this one hour but yeah I'll come with
a few examples
and there won't be a full list but like
I'll pick an example and I'll mention
what exactly in my opinion went wrong
here and then hopefully you will
recognize yourself or
perhaps better if you do not forget you
say you'll never make this mistake
anyway
okay so let's start and I'll start by an
example of uh bad opening preparation
oh well we're all guilty for this
but that's a special case a special case
that some people might actually
kind of feel a bit familiar so I think
it was vishyanand recently yeah Wishy
you probably know who I'm talking about
right uh Vision on who in one of the
interviews he mentioned that it's better
not to know the opening at all than to
know 90 of it
well the percentage may vary but here's
the idea so it's very bad when you have
some
idea of the position in your head but
you do not exactly remember the moves
so what to do yeah I mean the obvious
would be learn the opening well but yeah
that's not why we are here so the idea
is that you should probably try if you
do not recall the moves exactly you
should probably try just to pretend okay
you don't know here's the position I
have to play it because the thing I'll
show now it's my game once again it'll
be my games
uh my game against Boris girlfriend well
known quite known chess player and
played the world championship match
uh okay when I
went for a specific line having limited
knowledge
and then yeah okay let's let's just go
on uh do we have the board on the screen
hopefully the answer is yes okay so I
was playing Black it's
um don't recall the year around
2007 8 9 something like that
so quite some time ago
and I always had difficulties preparing
against very very top players
because yeah they I always felt
semi-professional right even like having
a rating close to 2700 I always felt
like yeah
that that's not something that I'm doing
full time right and it worked till some
extent but then I would face uh this you
know wizards of Chess Vince was
encyclopedic knowledge and I would
suffer so for Boris I had to prepare
basically before the game and that
that's usually very tricky because you
open the database you see the guy is
playing absolutely everything
and then well perhaps I should have just
closed and went for a walk but I didn't
okay so I prepared this line
which is what's it called semi-slav
right here goes E3
and after he goes E3 I understand ah
okay that's Boris he knows everything
about my run variation and time around
and so on and so on
so and there was this strange hybrid
line popular
uh at the time
so
with the pawn on E7 we would be talking
about chebanenko's love right so A6 and
then the attempt to develop the bishop
and then go V6
or if I would play quote unquote normal
move Knight D7 then it's a run variation
or very likely Queen to C2 and on timer
on in boris's case
so I went for a mixture of those I went
A6 he goes C5 grabs the space
Knight to D7 and yeah C5 is only one of
the possible moves so white has white
has A4 white has Knight to E5 I believe
you can still play a move with the
bishop E2 or D3
right so C5 here I had some specific
picture in my head what I should be
aiming for
but I had no idea about the precise move
zorim
so I'm playing my moves he plays his
moves Knight to D7 that well
if you look at the structure it's clear
black has to try to go for E6 E5 right
so I went Queen C7
because I thought yeah well I'm sporting
E5 and stuff believe it or not it's move
seven it's already if not the decisive
mistake it's a huge mistake a very
natural myth which opts for e75
a e65 button yeah Bishop to B2
then I realized that E5 is
not very good to put it mildly because
he's going to take take trade everything
and then Knight A4 and that makes it
incredibly awkward Knight A4 Knight to
B6 and so on
but
still had some you know some idea that
G6 Bishop G7 this is how I have to
oppose the wishbone B2
so I went for it G6
and yeah and girlfriend you have to know
him I mean when he knows the opening he
plays incredibly quickly so I felt under
pressure already
like he just blitzes out the moves all
the time
Bishop to G7 Knight to A4 once again
that was played very quickly so before
that you kind of turn to believe the guy
he knows something okay he will cancel
now and I'll be relaxed yeah but then he
very quickly plays Knight A4 I cancel he
castles
and here's the thing black is still not
lost of course I mean Black's position
is probably worse but not not like
saying not dramatic but I still had this
idea that I'm supposed to play E6 E5 and
that's what I've done
E5
he captures with the Knight yeah okay we
could look at this position a little bit
if he takes with the pawn
just go to G4 and I win the E5 Pawn back
and I'm getting acceptable position
that's perhaps let's not dig too deep
there
so the critical moment is that he takes
with the Knight Knight takes Pawn takes
and I go to G4 I thought it is the same
right so if you have a place F4 I'll
just take the E3 Pawn
Knight B6 I'm not really scared of
uh wait a second why I'm not scared of
Knight B6 now I I don't even remember
yeah so The Rook is hanging right I'll
have to play Rook B8 ah he takes C8
attack C8 with the queen okay so the
Knight is still protected and the bishop
is pinned on B2 so there is no E6 of any
sort okay and losing this bishop or
trading this bishop for the Knight is
not of my biggest concerns
anyway so I was relatively happy with my
position up to the point and girlfriend
is still blitzing just to let you know
it's move 14. and he goes Bishop E2
and here I realized how terrible that is
so Bishop to E2
now my problem is
okay my problem is that Knight of G4 is
hanging I can't really do anything else
but to take on E5
and then it goes pretty forcing he goes
F4
CES my knight on D7 otherwise I'm
dropping material he trades on G7
ah battery trade zone G7 gives a check
on D4
turns out blocking with the Knight on F6
loses to G2 G4
and G5 is inevitable
so I have a very sad choice between
playing F6
or going King G8
both of them are terrible I went with
King G8 and I've lost quite quickly
after E4 takes Knight C3 and then the
Knight takes only four Bishop goes to C4
and so on we can quickly run through
this game through this Miz but then I'll
explain why this game is shown at all
so I went day five uh not the best move
but even the best move is not saving you
against a decent player here Bishop to
C4 and pretty much you cannot defend
your King's side
so I went with some imitation of a
contemplate with some B6 hopefully he's
going to take or something Rook to D1
Queen to B2 and that's that's just that
just terrible so these guys still cannot
move you move the Knight Knight F6 game
over right you move the bishop first of
all where do you move the bishop and
even if you go to A6 then Rook to D7
finishes you
so I went Rook d8
with a slight hope that he is going to
take Rook takes Knight F6 okay we can we
can go through this variation
well Bishop takes for that matter Knight
F6 King f8
check King G8 I'm still lost there don't
get me wrong but at least I was hoping
for the game to drag a little bit but
after Rook d8 he just uh
just Place Bishop F7
and that was it I just
just resigned it's a point being
if you take he gives you check on G5
first
and then
yeah King G8 Queen 2 B3
so that that's a check and if King gets
to h8 it's Queen F7 I can't really stop
Queen H7 checkmate
all right that was a bit clumsy but what
exactly went wrong I knew I had the
correct idea of going E5
just the thing is that it's properly
done in a little bit different way so
after B4 I had to Friendship to my
Bishop first and let's continue with all
the myths that white has played in the
games G6 Bishop B2 Bishop to G7 Bishop
D3 castles
consoles let's go Queen to E7 instead of
Queen C7 that's a very important
difference that if I knew this line like
hundred percent if I would know it by
heart I would play that move Knight A4
is exactly the same position with the
little twist so the queen is on E7 not
C7 and now E5 works as I suspected it to
work
so the difference being that if he does
exactly all the same
and Knight to G4
and Bishop to E2
I can just take
and then if he goes F4 so it's exactly
the same thing
except
when he takes on G7 I can take opponent
with the check
so that's a little difference
which you probably not aware of let's
say move seven because it's too far away
so you really have to know it or other
option you don't know a thing about this
position and still you do not move the
queen on move seven right you first
develop the bishop and then close it at
the moment where you play E5 you're
probably able to figure out
uh so how to avoid these things so once
again you either know so ideal case
scenario you just know you're opening
lines but this will never happen of
course right so the second option if you
have like some knowledge but you do not
do not remember
entirely yeah clearly it's better
kind of
say to yourself right tell yourself okay
we do not know everything let's try to
construct let's try to play the game
from this position because it's been
many times at least in my practice that
I have some visualization of what's
going to happen in the game and I'm
trying to kind of reconstruct it
backwards and I'm playing the move just
to realize that made a terrible mistake
okay so I'm trying to
trying to see trying to see the chat a
little bit reverse engineering yeah kind
of uh yeah it is on Twitch I believe
this stream isn't like every single
platform right yeah it's on a lot of
platforms yeah that's cool so
we are not yet done with this example
simply because yeah after that was Queen
on E7 I wanted to get this one
come on now I'm kind of lost a little
bit
not a big expert on using leeches ah
yeah okay here we are
so after Knight G4 with the queen on E7
however he has one more trick
which is
Knight two
Knight to B6 and it might be a little
scared
because now if you remember Rook B8
Knight takes we were taking with the
queen to protect the G4 Knight
but now well with Queen on E7 we do have
we do have the other idea which is
Bishop takes E5 and once again of course
it's easy to miss unless you know the
opening right so Bishop to E5
and the only kind of quote-unquote hard
variation is if he actually takes the
Rook Bishop A2 Queen H4 but okay it's
not that hard perhaps
yeah
ah all right so this is more about GM
mistakes not Club level mistakes uh yeah
perhaps I had to start with this because
yeah obviously there will be
not in these games but yeah there are
examples of say I blunder Queen I make a
mistake yeah
okay hang my queen in one move that's
okay but for this you know it it's a
silly advice to give but the better you
get in the game the less of those like
really stupid you make and what I'm
trying to describe here is kind of a
universal thing so it's a mistake in a
way of thinking
it's not a mistake that like yeah it's
not like you give a rope for free right
it is categorized the mistake but these
mistakes that I'll be talking about I
believe they're
viable for every level
I mean that that might be a bit less
complex more complex but they're on
every level people do make such mistakes
and like if you think of elite players I
believe there have been examples of say
Maxim vashilagrove who is in love with
his groomfield and neither very Theory
heavy sharp openings right that he while
being one of the best players in the
world in this opening sometimes he would
confuse the line and loosen the spot
how to make mistakes for GM for dummies
yeah twitch chat has it you see that
that's a proper title for this lesson
absolutely so what I was saying yeah
Knight takes A8 uh Queen age works and
if he captures only five so this is the
one perhaps a little bit tricky line
Bishop takes Queen takes we threaten the
checkmate
after G3 we can go Queen H5 once again
intermediate move tracking a Checkmate
and after H4 we are safe to move the
Rook because now now Knight on G4 is
protected white can capture white can go
Bishop E2 but after F5 Black is Black is
perfectly fine
so that was it for for this example
okay
then example number sample number two
which is
I think we jump from the beginning of
the game from
the opening right to the end of it
because I just want to give an easy
example
uh
perhaps yeah like my colleagues chess
players will be mad at me right now but
I'll tell you something quick chat and
all the other chats and everyone who is
watching chess is a natural brain
activity
in what way so it doesn't matter how
intense your work is it tends to
you know fluctuate the level of the peak
of concentration and then you're allowed
to relax a little bit like doesn't
matter what kind of problems you're
solving and chess is not forgiving in
this regard I played 40 brilliant
positional moves right played the
Masterpiece and then blunder the rook
and lost
so that kind of neglects all my previous
work
so once again you probably get by this
point that what mistakes I'm gonna talk
about right so when I'd say after
the closer to the end of the game you
I don't know you just lose concentration
it's very hard to do something about it
but having the understanding that yeah
the brain simply turns to relax
very often it would be in the position
that you consider winning
and there will be an example
about that but before that I'll show you
how to make this mistake without making
a move
uh it's a huge game it's very painful
game for me because
because reasons so I'll show you the
final position
funny enough it was played in 2005
it was annotated for chess Base by
somebody I don't know not me
so 2005 means chess engines would
already be around and yet
my mistake went unnoticed even by
annotated with a with an engine
it was a second game of a World Cup
match I won the first one and okay in
this game it's been a lot of stuff I was
winning I was I don't know having a draw
is enough of course to to qualify for
the next round and okay I'll show you a
few moves
so here I am defending even number of
pieces even number of Pawns but my king
is terrible on on H7 right
so now going back means a Checkmate on
h8
I block with the Rook
uh Queen F5 I have to defend the Rook
which has been so my only move is King
to G7
he gives another check forces me to
block with the Rook and he goes Queen E5
and that's the moment when I
felt like okay I probably had enough
it's not that hard to figure out okay if
the King goes I'm getting checkmated
after G8 it's one move after f8 it's
you know three moves to check here check
here I mean probably you don't need to
calculate because white winds in many
ways but it's a nice Checkmate like this
for instance and so on and so on and you
can block with the Rook but then he
gives a check and takes the rule that's
how the calculation works okay at least
for me right so these things I see a
blunt the piece I stop calculating
so
a challenge is to make a mistake in this
position without making a move and it's
accomplished by resigning the game and
preparing for the direct
right
the moral of this story is that if you
say if you play the game in a worse
position just make sure that your fight
and concentrate and not like just make
moves because why I've resigned here
it's not because before before this I
didn't realize my position was bad I was
just making random moves I said the
position was such already for like five
minutes ten minutes so I was forced to
defend and basically just avoiding a
Checkmate in a couple of minutes
and yeah F6 by the way someone mentioned
in the chat yeah F6 uh runs it to Queen
E7 just forgotten to forgotten tell you
and then King G8 loses The Rook
and queen F7 sorry and queen F7 loses
the queen after Rook H2
yeah so
since I was playing
I should have looked for resources to
fund
and in this case I absolutely had to
play Rook M6
and I think someone in chat already has
mentioned it out stalemate stalemate
yeah that's the point which I missed
entirely it's not such a hard stalemate
it's a study like stalemate but not a
hard one so after Rook G1 what I should
have done I mean had I played Rook F6 I
should have pulled the saddest face I
have in go King H7 like preparing for
resignation when you take my Rook
because if you take my Rook it's
actually Queen A2 double exclamation
mark followed by B3 and Mira goes to the
next you know next match in the World
Cup because it's a draw
so the whole point is like if you
continue playing in bad position at
least look for resources because I've
seen it and I've done it many times and
I've seen people doing this so I don't
want to resign because I don't know the
mom's gonna be angry or yeah I've got
nothing to do so let's just play a few
more moves I mean if you're playing the
game play the game
uh truth been told this is not a draw
white still has close to decisive
advantage
but of course it's a huge chance that
I've missed simply by not continuing the
game
okay that was game two example two
and then losing the concentration
uh later in the game and also
it kind of correlates with the other
mistake that I tend to make a lot I
don't know if you people ever do
but those are the games that are the
most painful to lose when you fail
during the game that you're a genius
you're creating a masterpiece okay I'm
I'm kidding of course but yeah sometimes
you're kind of carry getting carried
away with the playing a nice game and so
on and
what's a dangerous thought is let me win
it in a nice way I don't know if it ever
crossed your mind I think I'm kind of
catching myself doing it way too often
so that yeah okay this looks such a nice
game and if it will get a beautiful
finish maybe it's get published
so it's um it's a game against
um Alexander believski four times
four times USSR Champion which counts
for something
and
interestingly enough I've I've managed
to play
I've managed to play a few games against
him but scored only half a point
all right and that was the game that I
was very close to winning and winning in
Styles I don't know if we should kill
like through the entire game but let's
try let's try
okay the opening perhaps yeah I will not
talk much about the opening it's a
shameful opening that's what I'm playing
all my life with white so don't be too
hard on me
a ready opening and specifically this
one B takes E4 is so called reti Gambit
which actually quite often if I'm trying
to be serious it quite often leads to
very interesting positions you have to
know
some Theory and that's kind of specific
for this line you it has no analogs and
the other in the other similar lines
anyway so castles are now
to my knowledge like the main move
considered to be Knight D7 where white
has two choices
and rather you go Queen C2 he goes
Knight B6 guards the pawn and here white
has two choices you can go Knight A3
immediately or you can include a2a4
planning to attack the Knight he'll
replay reply with A5 and you have pretty
much the same position with or without a
to A4 A7 A5 included
but yeah but that's a lot of lot of
theory it's quite an interesting line
anyway belevski goes E7 E6 something new
to me
I go A4
so now planning for Knight A3 and kind
of try to win the pawn back
B6
and B6 I remember B6 kind of surprised
me quite a bit
because it feels really awkward
so now after B6 I can yeah I went Knight
E5 attacking both C6 and C4
he goes Bishop B7 and here I can take
the pawn back have an equal material and
probably slightly better position so
typical you know Catalan
Catalan Bishop well I'll eventually play
d2d4 or maybe modest D3 probably a
slightly better position
but yeah but I I just had this you know
this strange what if
let's let's try to be
let's try to be a little bit more
aggressive so I went Knight A3 now the
difference of course would be if he
continues developing I'll take with this
Knight right and the Knight only five is
is really nicely placed
but Knight A3
involves a pawn sacrifice yeah after
Knight A3 he captures and he has
Queen deformer which attacks by Knight
guards the C4 for one so meaning I'm not
winning the pawn back Knight to F3
Queen to D6 is what he did
and yeah and I'm not reading the pawn
back after Queen C2 he can play Bishop
A6
it's a very risky business for black
because I can I mean there is if you're
a little bit familiar with reti Gambit
you would probably know that there is a
lot of I would say a cluster of
positions where white sacrifices the
pawn and has kind of long-lasting
compensation so I wasn't that unhappy
about this position
and I went with d2d3 which is an
interesting take so usually if this Pawn
survives it's uh it's exchanged for the
B Pawn and then white tries to take the
center but here I felt like it's a
little different so I went with D3
Rook takes Queen E7
so white already has quite a huge
compensation I developed it with Knight
E5 Bishop G5 so far nothing to be like
bragging about why it plays natural
moves and black steel has like Knight on
B8 undeveloped and so on
mm-hmm
H6 caption F6 Queen F6 so um here I had
once again it's not about mistakes but
just to get you a little bit more in my
way of thinking about this game so here
I had some doubt about playing Bishop G5
because I'm almost forced to trade it
for a night
and that's part of my compensation part
of my hope for an advantage is a pair of
Bishops and specifically the dark Square
Bishop which has no no position so to
speak right but then I thought that it
cannot go wrong as long as I'm planning
a playing kind of moves forward
everything's logical and in order to
train my Bishop he once again delays the
development of the joseon ba
it's H6 I trade here now of course you
wouldn't like to live from E5 so that's
why F4 is played
going to E7 Queen to D2 was the move I
was
exceptionally proud of even though it's
it's very silly right I mean it's just
the move to D2 but the thing is the next
move because key ones he White Queen E7
he wants to protect the bishop and go C5
trade Bishops girl 96 and so on he's
ready to give away his extra Pawn at any
moment
to have pleasure of finishing the
development and making it draw
and queen D2 of course yeah on the
surface you can see I'm planning to
Triple my stuff on the D file but also
after C5 I have a little move E3 so if
he trades I take with the queen and he's
still unable to you know kind of untie
this note of pieces on the queen side
he actually has to play A5 which is a
terrible looking position from
positional standpoint it's a terrible
looking move but he needs some squares
for the Rook so that he can trade on G2
and when The Rook is attacked at least
it's not trapped
yeah so Rook D1 then I will just go over
till next critical moment because for
the time being undoing I'm playing if
not the best moves but close to the best
and
okay it's just a cool game I'm so happy
with myself finally after losing a
couple of games against belevsky finally
I have him
it's a queen to C2 now now I want to get
the queen on C4 B5 something so I'm not
even in rush to win the pawn back right
I like to feel control of me
Queen to C4 once again not letting him
to play C4 the Knight is still kind of
tied down to B8
Queen C8 Queen to B5 and and that's the
moment when I'm starting to enjoy myself
because it's such a you know no
sacrifice but such a beautiful
positional masterpiece
C4
then yeah the position is ripe enough we
have to start taking some stuff Queen A5
Rook takes B2
and why yeah why I'm saying all that
nonsense because really white is winning
like if you ask the machine despite
being a pawn down white is like white is
winning it's a huge Plus for white
but
coming back to this idea of Chess being
unnatural brain activity
so this was a tense game from the
beginning right and now I realize that
I'm winning and I see in the eyes of my
opponent that he kind of kind of gives
up
and I relaxed
and um
here I wasn't even sure why he went for
this line because it's so obvious that
he is lost and he even takes on B2 so
I'm playing move number 27 rook d8 and
I'm waiting for him to resign because
what's that he's losing the queen or if
he moves the queen I take on a fate and
Checkmate him and the guy goes Queen B7
and finally I understand what what's
going on so I give a check without much
of a hope that he's going to take the
Rook because the Checkmate didn't want
and he goes to H7 and it's a first
moment of panic
it's a first moment of panic because I'm
about to get checkmated on YouTube
and I think it would be instructional if
if I would be losing here but no
luckily
the way I've played it previously I mean
all the all the positional gains they
were not for
not for nothing and white is still much
better
and I'm kind of getting this shock I'm
concentrating and I'm able to find the
Right Moves so I go Rook D5
Rook D5 yeah I have to have to part with
material otherwise I'm getting
checkmated Rook D2 might seem kind of an
illusion of
uh yeah defending the king but then it's
a check and if I'm not mistaken Queen H1
and then he gets gets to the king and
I'm actually I actually do get
checkmated
Knight F3 doesn't help yeah Queen D2
Chad suggests yeah Queen D2 perhaps is
possible but first of all
he can take and he's not worse right
because the king is very big
probably yeah probably that's what he
has to do he just captures and say he
goes let me think of it because I
remembered this one not being too great
maybe he goes up six
like attacks the Knight which will have
to go to G4
so Queen D2 is Stella wasn't happy
anyway my Rook D5
tend to be a very good move
Rook D5
and now if the pawn takes I'm no longer
getting checkmated so that means he's
getting jackmated so it's Queen d8
a check here I go King G2
not being afraid of any ghosts because
either it's D4 or queen B2 I go to H2
uh H3 burn and and yeah no no more
checks
so he has to trade the Queens the queen
takes
Queen takes
Pawn takes
and yeah
and here I'm kind of back on track
back on track winning this game
and all I had to do here was take the
pawn
plain and simple take the pawn now if he
tries to promote the C Pawn I'm just in
time with Rook to C7
he goes C2 threatens a check
girl knight D3
and he gives me a check
and this is what stopped me
and I went key I would go King F2 Rook
D1 attacking the Knight and I'm just on
time whisking into
so I'm winning the pawn
I'm still not sure if I would have won
the game this way because black is not
resigning black and I don't know play
Rook A1 take this guy or play Rook H1
take the other guy but we shouldn't
argue that white is close to winning
it's an end game with an extra Pawn with
a weakness on D5 yeah like say this one
right takes takes uh much better pieces
the king is especially kind of yeah it's
the end game so King has to participate
and so on but yeah but the problem is I
mean first of all
I was getting a little bit low on time
but second I thought okay it was a
positional Masterpiece then I sacrificed
Back The Rook on D5 so let's finish it
off in style and I started the
calculator I had like 10 minutes or so I
started to calculate and I got
absolutely carried away so
uh this is like first of all of course
me being
uh how to say somewhat tired and losing
the concentration which allowed this
whole Rook B7 and him all of a sudden
pieces that did not move all of a sudden
creating Checkmate threads right so I
was better off not taking on B6 and
therefore not going Queen B5
like another prophylactical move would
be just just a win right
yeah and then here instead of capturing
I for whatever reason decided that that
we need we need to you know we need to
win
F5
C3 Knight takes F7
I'm threatening a checkmate
yeah of course and I even calculated the
lines that he goes G6 I go F6 the same
Checkmate is threatened and then he goes
G5 I can play Knight E5 exclamation mark
so I'm in time to stop the pawn because
if you go C2 it's still a Checkmate
because it's a check on F7 so I've
calculated some lines right check over
here and then check over here if he ever
happens to go to the corner it's Knight
G6 right or Knight F7 he goes there it's
Knight G6 followed by F7 so I've
calculated the longest line and I'll
promote with the check I win
cool story
but if I wouldn't be
you know
carried away and would not lose the
concentration that much I would probably
ask myself dude if he if you've already
calculated G6 F6 G5 do you know that
this Pawn can go two squares from G7
because that's exactly what happened he
played G5 and now in this beautiful line
that I've just calculated I'm a full
Tempo down which means the moment I'm
threatening a Checkmate he's promoting
on C1 and and that's it
so there was a moment of panic but this
time it was already too late to panic
so I went 95 C2 and I have no other move
but Knight D3
so that was the only way not to not to
lose on a spot but that's a technical
and a technical end game and
uh you know if you are four times
Soviet Union Champion probably you know
how to win with an extra piece at least
believe happened to know so the rest of
this game is not important
uh okay so that was that was game game
three and I do have one more
I do have one more which does not
categorize all the mistakes so once
again game game with billowski here
it's yeah it is it was a heartbreaking
game because
and what there was yeah if we dig a
little bit about the history of this one
it was uh
it was a weekend or extended weekend in
Austrian league on Austrian Bundesliga
so European leagues usually played
most of them are played not in one go
but throughout the season for weekends
you you arrive you play a couple of
games and so on and extended weekend by
means you had four games starting from
Thursday and yeah to Sunday and I've
played believe it or not but I've played
three games like this I scored half out
of four playing close to the best chess
in my life just I mean just making these
silly mistakes around me 40. so there
were three very entertaining very very
interesting games
right
I don't feel so bad about my game yeah
okay and then the
the last one the last one
uh it'll be more about okay there'll be
a few mistakes in one game which usually
is um is the case but to describe what
affected me because yeah like once again
as I'm saying like blundering a rook is
a mistake
but it's fine right I mean at some point
you learn how not to how the pieces work
and you'll not want
uh not being able to calculate some
variation because it was too hard and
missing a move is fine
also happens to the best of us but like
kind of calculating wrong variations on
losing their big objectivity which will
happen in our game this time this is
what I think is kind of fundamental flow
which you can get rid of
so here's the situation I'm rated 26 24
and that's after I've lost a lot of
ratings so of course I'm
you know have a perception of me being
close to 2700. and now I'm playing the
guy in the Bundesliga German Bundesliga
this time who is rated 100 points lower
so I expect him to play even worse and
myself even better
okay sorry uh point being I'm trying to
win this game with black so starting
from one I'm playing kind of dubious
opening and when it works out I'm trying
to
now to say I'm trying to
avoid any simplifications or major
simplifications I'm trying to keep the
game going
um yeah and up to the point it was
working fine
was okay
but then I completely lost it out of my
mind right I was neglecting all the
Joyce lines and going for the other okay
this line it's a draw this Line's a draw
let's go for this one and inevitably you
end up at some point
picking the wrong wrong the Lost line
yeah a cool observation yeah I imagine
some sorry some people getting it with a
little bit of a delay but cool
observation about the game with
billowski that he has won with his
Knight still being on B8
this night that I was trying to prevent
from at least I've succeeded in one
thing this night has never moved now it
actually did yeah I just can't cut the
rest of the game because yeah he was
with an extra piece and he did but when
he met this night that that was there
was Nightmare
uh all right so we will try to quickly
go through through this one
Knight F6 yeah today earlier today I had
a I had a lesson with the school kids
and I was telling them a true story
absolutely why I'm such a fan of uh
other kind defense
because when I started as a little kid
and probably you have such experience
that you coach tells you and you're a
little kid so you tend to believe the
adults right he tells you okay play E4
then develop the Knight then develop the
bishop then castle and then you're free
to do whatever you want to do
so I was a smart kid I realized that a
lot of people do this so I really
enjoyed quite a few games when I would
be a pawn Apple move too
because yeah I mean they're told to
develop the Knight and then the bishop
and so on so I would take and it lost it
to such a point that I was playing a
kind against people was 26.50 it was
2700 which is not a very good opening
anyway for this game
I deliberately chose it I had some other
some other ideas
uh but yeah for this game I deliberately
chose it because I knew that my opponent
will play this
four Pawns
and it's actually a great system black
is in with this perfect kind of being
perfectly honest black is in quite a bit
of trouble in four points but somehow
since I'm motivated to disbalance the
game since I want to win
I wouldn't mind it okay so that's one of
the one of the theoretical lines Bishop
p7 nowadays I don't think they played
actually quite dubious
there should be two consoles castles and
black girls F6 so here in case you're
wondering takes on F6 is a very good
move and white is better which is no
surprise don't play Alika in defense
or if you do
learn another line against four Pawns
but quite often Whitewood girl knight H4
and that's what my opponent did in in
this game
it's not a terrible mistake but this
LEDs black to equalize quite comfortably
uh should black play H6 instead
I'm afraid it's it's too slow
H6 here I honestly I've never seriously
thought about this position I just
remember that F6 was considered to be
the move and the resulting position is
somewhat you can check Naka versus
Magnus in database and
this will give you an idea what line
currently stands Against full Pawns in
another kind there was a game of Magnus
constant against Nakai in one of those
endless
we call it Magnus tour whatever it's
called on internet when they play those
Rapids
so F6 984 I'll just go quickly through
those moves because this is not where we
make mistakes and they'll be that later
on yeah so he takes Knight F5 EF5 D5 a
lot of people go for this line because
um they think black has to retreat back
and then white is getting like like
enormous initiative like if I go to B8
and he goes C5 and Bishop C4 and like
everything is going forward
but of course yeah black has a little
trick of his own he goes back returns
back the pawn by going Knight D4
and now you kind of have to take it
because you cannot play C5 anymore right
so takes take stakes and black is I
wouldn't claim black is better but black
is perfectly fine because of those like
dark squares right and and King side
majority that you sometimes have like
this position you would have from
various
um
what's it called Knight of Knight of
Sicilians there are sometimes such
positions like well white jumps to D5
black exchanges on D5 and yeah something
like that anyway so black girls 97
somewhat naive but efficient threat of
Bishop C5
and let me let me get to the first
positioning question yeah The Rook a to
E1
uh what's interesting here I remember I
spent around 14 minutes discussing
with myself a philosophical question
should I go Rook E8 or first
move the queen and then go rookie eight
which would lead pretty much to the same
position so that that's a little mistake
but uh and and yet maybe out of our list
but sometimes
you know people tend to concentrate on
things that are not that important like
if it leads to the same position just
pick a move and do it yeah okay
rookie eight Bishop to C2 I've traded
when Queen f8 and G3 rookie okay not all
of those moves are obvious but I'm
aiming at a specific position
trade it here came to G2 Bishop C5 Queen
D2 Queen E5 Queen to E2 okay so
something like that so before that I can
say black was doing logical things and
white was doing it what he was allowed
to do I mean White's position was
somewhat worse
so here black has
what I Now understand a very attractive
move which is Bishop to D4 and obviously
I've kind of seen it
Bishop to D4
and white is in quite a bit of trouble
because Queen takes
and I remember like I've calculated
something I wasn't happy with say Knight
takes
uh sorry Knight takes E5 Knight B5
Bishop
I know he can wait a sec yeah Bishop B2
and some Bishop B3 something like that
and it's getting sharp he's winning the
pawn back I'm probably not better
anymore
but yeah but you can take with the
bishop that's the thing you can take
with the bishop and if black ever gets a
chance to trade on C3
I cannot guarantee black is winning but
that's at least we are getting there
like black is certainly better
oh sorry so I absolutely should have
gone for Bishop D4 Bishop takes E5 he's
moved not to get into like real trouble
is Knight to D1 and I should have just
played this position okay if I don't win
I don't win
okay but I got carried away with this
idea so far so far by the way it's not a
mistake yet Queen B4 but that's kind of
walking into a somewhat dangerous
Direction because after Queen D4 the
thing is yeah I mean he can give a check
and take the Knight right
for now he is getting checkmated though
so perhaps I have to show like at least
some variations to explain what I was
thinking about because it will be
relevant later on I'll get in a Time
trouble and make a mistake in a Time
trouble because of first of all not
having enough time and also because of
my over-aggression I was kind of
neglecting all the possibilities to make
a draw because I wanted to win so here
he still cannot take the Knight because
it's uh let me recall I think that yeah
both lead to a Checkmate so now King F3
it's a Checkmate from F1 or F2 King H3
it's a check King goes and then very
conveniently I have a king on f8 so
Bishop only seven wins wins the queen
so it's a night sacrifice but not really
he cannot take it but why there why 24
is a point of no return is because he
played Knight B5
I give a check on G1 he goes to H3
and now yeah now basically he is
threatening some stuff like check or you
know check on E8 or capture on C7
but I
what's blending for that and here I
still have the time and I have two move
candidates interestingly enough now that
I'm more experienced I can actually tell
that there is only one move
but I for some reason decided there is
term
so I've spent nearly all of my time
calculating Knight F6
which would have been
a right thing to do
so I'm trying to get the Knight on G4
interestingly enough my king is almost
like on its own but it's never getting a
Perpetual check because I will run to H6
so Knight G4 is a serious threat
and being not a bad player at least at
that time I understand that his only
idea to fight against my idea is to go
D5 D6
yd5 D6 because the bishop is very
helpful controlling the dark squares
sometimes Bishop would block on f8 so he
wants to
block this
diagonal for the bishop namely like if I
simply take with the pawn he has this
check followed by this check right
all right
so I realize I can still capture it it's
all in my head I'm calculating this line
right I can capture and he can capture
and I will give him an illusion that he
wins a piece
and I will go here and then all of a
sudden I win the piece back by giving a
check on F1 check on C4
and capture on C2 so you see I mean I I
wasn't that bad at calculation but
because I want to win this game I'm not
happy with this position because I see
through it and I see that he has a
Perpetual check
so I'm not happy with him making a
drawing like 15 moves line
but it turns out there is not much to do
other than playing Knight F6 and then I
come with a brilliant idea
yeah
uh let's go 95 so that I'm blocking the
E file
I'm still kind of Almost sure he cannot
take because it's the same check check
and I'll take one of his pieces that's
but you can already notice you know
I would say
if we are to pick the name for it for
this for this kind of
flow
in a way of thinking I would say
comforting myself because one line I was
very specific I've calculated like 15
Mills very precise the other one because
I'm not happy with the first yeah I'm
saying okay 95 if he takes I'll find
something it's already a little bit
a little bit strange right
so
95 and I'm telling myself okay if he's
gonna take at the very least I have a
Perpetual check
let's recall that a few minutes ago I
wasn't happy with the draw right but
just I'm giving myself more and more
reasons to play Knight E5 and not to go
for not to go for for the silly draw
right I'm comforting myself with like I
will have a Perpetual check
okay the guy takes he's merciless I go
for this idea that I give a check and I
give a check to see what happens
I realized that probably if he goes to
H3 it's actually too risky to take one
of the dudes because he will I don't
know give checks and so on
so I'm already coming
to terms with the ideas that I will give
a Perpetual check and then he goes to G5
and I realize I do not have a Perpetual
check
the game is still going though
I have a few minutes left
and here
so once again I'm committing the same
mistake that that's my favorite thing to
approach
various chess calculations so-called the
method of exclusion method of
elimination right so you have a few
options you kind of not happy with two
you go for the third one which is cool
and all but sometimes it backfires badly
so at least yeah the entire
let's say process should be that you at
least calculate each option a bit
because what happened here what happened
here once again the same the same
problem we are getting we are getting
actually getting yeah it's a little bit
over the time limit but we are getting
very close to the end
uh what happened two captures otherwise
I'm a piece down right
and what I've calculated is I've started
for some reason with the night capture
because intuitively I felt that this is
more promising and once again
I'm being
I'm being brilliant I'm finding that
interestingly enough the same D6 is a
very strong move here
but this this time it's very
straightforward he opens the diagonal
and like Bishop joins and I'm on the
very very bad attack
I do not have any other option but to
take
he gives a check on B3 that's what I
thought
and say regrettably this line doesn't
work because he's almost checkmated but
but not really right I mean he has two
squares
but I'm already kind of aware that maybe
there is some some Checkmate so he gives
a check I go over here
and then
truth being told white is better but why
it's not winning by force okay let's
let's just stop over there but but why
um why I've decided not to
kind of not to take on B5
I ended up capturing on C2 which loses
trivially in a couple of months so that
that's the moral of the story why
um I've decided not to take on B5
because in the calculated to this
position I'm already short on time right
and he goes Queen E6 that's what I
thought
and that's a brilliant way to win for
him because he's threatening a Checkmate
in one and if I go to E8 Queen F6
actually wins
yeah
it's hard to avoid such mistakes but
once again the advice would be if you
calculate the line make sure that your
calculation is like as close to correct
as possible because if I went through
all this why to stop why not to find
Bishop E3 which wins for black that's a
beautiful Checkmate because if he
captures it's actually discover check
with a four and when he takes it's Queen
F5
so there is absolutely no guarantee that
this position would happen
there's
yeah because say he can first of all you
have to seek when he seeks right I mean
one one could be tempted to just like
collect couple of Pawns after which
black is in the in a huge trouble let's
say let's say here
because the H Pawn is very dangerous and
white king oddly enough being on G6 is
quite safe
but yeah but you have to see such
resources if you calculate this line at
all and if I would have been kind of a
bit more efficient and I would not
dig too deep in Queen B5 but as it
turned out not deep enough and I would
calculate the other line for a couple of
moves I would realize that after Queen
C2 King F6 it's sort of Lights Out
because that's exactly what happened
and
the Checkmate is threatened and I've
somehow managed to drag the game for a
little bit by going Queen E4 that's the
only way not to get checkmated
immediately so it's Queen E4 he takes on
C7 once again like Checkmate from every
possible angle I don't have any like
serious checks so the only thing I have
is Bishop D4 he takes he goes Queen E5
I'm forced to trade
yeah because they check from here it's
D6 check from here it's Queen E7 and
this is it
this is it like Queen f8 he trades and
checkmates mean in two moves
right so after Queen E5 he blocks with
the queen on E5 after all those
exchanges capture only five takes only
five
King F7 I was slightly hopeful somehow
maybe it's gonna work but yeah and I'm
not in a terrible time trouble by that
time and yeah and then he goes King D6
and King C7 and the pawn is faster so
the only way to be able to promote on
time would be to play G5 and then if he
goes King C7 we promote at the same time
but then he returns back
and this is it
so that's a very painful game to lose
when you basically trick yourself
because I'm 100 sure I've calculated
much more than my opponent in this game
and much more precise
and losing the first of all losing the
kind of the sense of danger at first
place like spending half an hour
calculating Knight F6 and going for
Knight E5 that's not uh that someone
would describe exactly as smart right
and also like being low on time I think
you should that's finally I mean you
understand it's a lot of this is
um
you know inspirational speech more than
anything right but the Practical advice
when you're short on time and you you
sure that you have a couple of options
uh try to shift between them like two
moves calculate two moves here can
create two moves here so you're getting
information from both sources because
that that's what happened to me when I
was uh picking what piece to take right
so I've basically spent all of my time
on Queen B3 still was enabled uh on
Queen B5 pattern still was unable to
calculate till the end and I kind of put
little to no effort to capturing on Sita
all right
um so that'd be it for today I believe
hopefully you'll find something useful
or if not at least entertaining
thanks very much
[Music]